comment ça marche
waouh si j'avais su un jour que ces
troisièmes aurait servi à faire une
entrée en roux et ben j'aurais fait 6
ans et pas 3 les amis on a tous cette
personne qui nous a mis au monde qui a
souffert le martyre pendant des seconds
des minutes des heures ou des jours pour
les plus malchanceuses et ça vous ne
devriez jamais l'oublier cette personne
n'a plus donné d'amour pour vous qu à
n'importe qui d'autre dans sa vie
et cette personne c'est votre maman je
suis désolé ça s'est mal passé entre
vous et votre mère je vous m malek cette
intro il y en a eu des embrouilles des
conflits parce qu'elle vous priver de
sorties ou d'écrans ou de world of
warcraft
alors que votre guide vous attendez pour
faire le dernier raid et louté
l'équipement le plus fort du jeu et non
je ne parle pas de vécu
les amis nous sommes aujourd'hui sur
mother simulateur nous allons apprendre
à gérer un bébé chute très curieux car
je n'ai que 22 ans je suis très loin
d'imaginer ce que c'est que d'avoir un
enfant j'avais le choix entre demander
des conseils à mc fly carlito ou jouer à
ce jeu j'ai préféré jouer à ce jeu dr
bruno mcfly deuxième enfant il est leur
fils bravo beau gosse let's go ou
bienvenue dans mother simulator vous
devrez traverser une série de tests
difficile pour prouver que vous êtes la
meilleure mère ou père sur la planète
il s'agira pour chaque test d'une série
d'épreuves qui devront être accomplies
aussi vite que possible à dingo moi j'ai
juste parce que je sais les challenge
premièrement rencontre le bébé en
regarder les mignons
on attend quoi mais gros mais c'est que
c'est une france ça va pas qu'est ce que
je fais il veut quand il veut une tétine
à mondiaux élite 2 ok tétine tient baise
la main de ton seigneur fils de pat
ampleur pas plus élevé jamais je vais
trouver là je vais trouver là la tétine
oui comment je la prends ok je lai châu
dans la bouche et ferme la pièce est
prête et vénère gros mais pourquoi tu
pleures groupe s'était donné la tétine
mais tiens mes fils d'homme tâter comme
ton père [ __ ] à il me fait peur mais
venons en au fait qui me fait peur je
les prises ont fait exprès je veux pas
tiens je te pose là attends je te pose
ou comment se pose au pardon merde
pardon pardon pardon tiens tiens ma vie
et mes toiles à tient la tétine fidji
plus qu'une seconde ils pensent à une
tétine je lui mets la tétine dans la
bouche et mona crache au visage
quelle est cette enfant du démon ok j'ai
pu les instructions mais a il fallait
laver la tétine [ __ ] c'est pas moi je
sais pas gros natsu il n'a pas donné pas
de tétines vieux ok donc faut que je
m'en suis robinet et que je l'avais la
tétine alors tires tu es content voilà
christophe fabre on s'est donné des
chaînes autres enfants ce magnifique on
dirait que votre enfant robot a fait
pipi notre couche walter couches ultra
absorbante et résistantes au feu
devraient vous aider à résoudre ce
problème
alors on y va plus tard fin du démon ça
faisait ça à chaque fois
alors il alla coup je la prends à sa pub
elle pue la poubelle
vénère non mais c'est un sketch grange
mais la puissante ou lapins ok ok j'ai
compris j'ai compris qu'il fallait que
je fasse ça en fait ok ça un panier de
basket
yes et ensuite il faut une couche et
lula qu'une couche 9 lie en aplat oui
voix mais qu'est-ce qui va pas infos que
je mets du tax son petit cul vite on va
tendre mondiales avait lavé la veinarde
tu vas aller là dessus mais non mais va
pas dans le tiroir à coup je suis
l'homme tu vas aller là dessus mais
[ __ ] vous en faites pas ça va aller
très vite
ok la couche hop ça dégage yes ce brave
okello bébé c'est normal ça se voyait du
temps vous en faites pas il va bien donc
je dis toi que tu viennes toi le cul tu
es toi le cul voilà je peux faire ce que
je fais
[Musique]
on va lire les instructions car
apparemment c'est pas s'occuper d'un
enfant alors alors alors si la couche à
des fuites jaune il faut la changer
c'est ce qu'on appelle des laurines bien
sûr le bébé n'aime pas rester mouillé
asperges ses fesses avec du talc
alors viens viens là bien un véritable
art de 22 secondes se paie ma vie est
dure voilà j'en ai mis mes fait chier
[ __ ] je veux pas d'enfant vraiment et
c'est parti la couche la gauche ya il
voit sa gueule les autres couches mais
ma vie est un skate pardon paquet
j'attends a alors n'hésitons plus tant
le cul tant que attention tu l'as où tu
l'as bien son cul c'est bon ok oh là là
mais je suis si fort il ya certaines
filles ont un projet d'enfant n'hésitez
pas à m'appeler chanter mon père [ __ ]
mais grosse et dure des parents là sans
déconner chaque seconde qui passe j'ai
un peu plus de respect pour ma maman et
mon papa c'est incroyable alors ton bébé
a faim
mais il se démerde vieux bien sûr
alloresto des livres où ils cassent pas
les couilles pour préparer sa nourriture
vous allez avoir besoin d'une petite
bouteille d'eau bouillante et d'y
ajouter la mixture par contre n'oubliez
pas de nettoyer la bouteille
effectivement ok allez ne soyez voilà on
pose on active le on met le biberon
dessous pour verser le mélange dans la
bouteille
vous avez besoin de mettre cette
dernière sur la table puis de prendre la
boîte de mixtures dans vos mains et de
cliquer sur la bouteille très bien
mais non mais [ __ ] voilà le beau brun
près vous en faites pas y'a plus qu'à
mettre le bouchon ok ce mardi on va
juste nettoyées comme ça il ira pas il
est content c'est mon enfant et les
couilles comme moi c'est sûr ça fait
quoi là
[Musique]
voilà a fait moins le malin malin on
fait moins le malin maintenant je suis
ton père tu me respectes pas petits
combats à l'est se dégage 500 ballons
assez l'ex-maire ça tient un bébé ça me
fatigue
je vais m'occuper de mon bébé comme il
se doit je vais pas paix mon enfant est
allé en prison
[Musique]
[ __ ] je suis prêt il faut faire un
enfant avec moi on y va oui je lisais un
truc la vérité qu'elle est trop souvent
il me dit le quart retour à mon âge et
comptera deux enfants tu te rendras
compte à quel point ma vie et pas si
simple à gérer mais oui oui je m'occupe
d'un bébé virtuel et je pète un cadre
déjà mois au ton bébé à saly tellement
de couches en voile et aussi vite que
possible pour gagner un maximum de
points
alors ça je suis pas seul dans la vraie
vie en face ce soir allons-y papa et les
basketteurs alors l'intoxication
alimentaire vous êtes empoisonné et
maintenant vous devez vous rendre aux
toilettes au à gauchy aisne bar qui
montre à quel point vous êtes mal voilà
temps je vais y aller maintenant je vais
y aller maintenant voilà c'est chaud là
mais n'importe quoi waouh il ya cabre
une foule qui a applaudi parce que j'ai
choisi pour y avancer à chaque fois ma
vie c'est formidable oui je dise la
vérité
on rigole on s'amuse mais vous verrez
que le jour où on sera tous papa ou
maman bas on se souviendra de ce jeu et
ça nous servira de ouf
mais je suis un père voire mountain of
gift au [ __ ] on dirait bien que votre
enfant veut jouer avec ses nombreux
jouets préférés déjà déjà cette fois au
moins il aura trois joué pas plus ok je
dois lui amener les jouets qui veut
c'est ça oh là là le fils d'homme je
dois trouver le jouet armées sarath il
c'est le même joueur voire exemplaire
vraiment les parents qui s'en remettent
pas trop pour les cadeaux qu'un beau
gosse [ __ ] c'est bleu élus enfants
violés vous avez vu comme j'étais excité
d'avoir un enfant début de cette vidéo
et qu'au bout de 1h à m'occuper
j'ai envie de l'abandonner je suis là
y'a pas l'option prêté le bébé aux
grands-parents l'abri dans la vraie vie
à ce à quoi des parents ils sont sous
les toits ils font quoi
mais ils appellent leurs parents eux et
ils t'offrent a eu comme ça pendant une
semaine allez dis moi que c'est la fin
tremblement de terre non mes mecs
alors je fais quoi tout va trembler je
veux être comme ça avec lui bros comme
un con
c'est pas grave je laisse ça va pas
arrêter
mère nature je m'embête à merde prix des
étoiles ses lakers aux normes du macabre
un tremblement de terre je lai je me
fiche de vos tremblement de terre mère
nature une sucette une tétine bardon
alors où est passée cette victime la
danse est un canard battus 5 ha d'ar
fils dope attendant dollar en or mais la
droite et il jette et ijet le mois
d'août il y est y avait bien sûr vibrato
l'inventaire toi fais partie n'ont pas
joué fair tir que j'achète mes chevaux
chiens pendant quatre alimentaire où
c'est dur tu veux quoi la couche et je
fais la couche en chef à kaka up
le tac le talk le tac le talent
tiens tiens la couche tient au quai
bravo papa reviens pas pas vos toilettes
j'arrive c'est bon j'ai des cernes
qu'ont poussé pendant la vidéo du mois
que c'est fini waouh
vous étiez tellement occupée vous n'avez
pas fait attention à la nuit qui arrive
à on doit se préparer du café
ok déjà tient jeune chien alors il est
où le café ou et le café ou et le café
1,6 à café il est là pour l'avs la tasse
et ensuite on la pose
[Musique]
je craque [ __ ] mais déjà des jardins
en 2018 à une espresso là tu fais pas
chier avec tes sachiez bordel à la ferme
qui veut un biberon by combien ben voilà
on va lui faire on va lui faire ça peut
être si compliqué parce qu'il vient en
tout cas c'est que la poudre a disparu
la poudre a disparu fils d'un peu plus
de bien là et bien là c'est pour tomber
à vraiment lâche peu plus de nourrir
j'en peux plus t'en fais pas c'est pour
ton bien mon fils voilà
gros je te respecte je viens de jouer un
jeu tu dois m'occuper d'un bébé je les
appelais fils dope c'était très dur sont
occupés donc je tenais à t'appeler pour
te dire bravo pas du tout tu me dis
toujours qu'un jour je me rendrai compte
de ce que c'est de ton travail au
quotidien
en tant que père de famille ouais est-ce
que tu as dû l'amener à la crèche
non non non est-ce que tu avais expliqué
que sa famille allait mourir bientôt
d'une maladie grave
non puisque ta bulle et expliqué que les
dinosaures avaient complètement disparu
premier nom voilà ça c'est leur
éducation
ok je veux pas d'enfant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]